hey what is up everyone it's animak here
for anime outpour and today i will be
breaking down the latest craziness in
black clover including asta's new devil
union samurai form yami finally joining
the fight and the dark truth about why
lucifero cannot be stopped no matter how
hard the black bulls try ladies and
gentlemen this was a crazy one so let's
get into it if you guys enjoy our black
clover videos and you want to see more
in the future you know the drill just
leave a quick like and comment right now
it only takes a second but it really
helps with the youtube algorithm and if
you're new to the channel or maybe you
watch our videos but you just haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
quick favor and make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications
it is a totally free but really
important way to directly support this
channel you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror a
big shout out to all of our anime uproar
patrons who make videos like this one
possible i will talk more about patreon
at the end of this video but first be
advised that this video will of course
contain black clover manga spoilers we
are dealing with the very latest events
in the story so please proceed with
caution you have been warned the action
picks up as the giant lucifero monster
continues to get stronger while the
black bull's base seems to have become
inoperable due to the damage it
sustained in the previous chapter in
fact not only is lucifero still standing
after that battle but he seems to be
moving beyond the point of just
possessing lower ranked devils to
actually manifesting fully into this
world and that would of course be an
absolute disaster for everyone at this
point time is not on the side of
humanity and unless they stop lucifero
now they may never stand a chance of
stopping him again if he manifests fully
into this world there is no way to know
just how strong he will become and what
crazy powers he will possess so allowing
him to manifest is a massive risk it
could literally be game over for
everyone in this incredibly difficult
moment only one man stands between
humanity and total disaster and that man
is of course our boy osta along with his
bro liebe we can't forget liebe back
when the black bulls were still piloting
the black bull mecca asta told the
others that he might know a way of
saving yami without hurting anyone and
that is when he left the mecca in order
to take his position on that hilltop
thanks to an assist from finral this is
the same hilltop that he appeared on at
the end of the previous chapter all the
black bulls gave us to their full
support and told them that he's got this
and again despite asta directly saying
that he will save captain yami no one
even mentioned poor william but what can
you do no one caring about william has
become a massive meme at this point
before going into battle austin liba
have a little strategy session where
they discuss their intentions and they
also remind themselves of what they are
fighting for they are not only fighting
to save yami and the entire spade
kingdom but they are also fighting to
avenge their mother lychita who was
killed by the very same devil who is now
threatening the safety of the entire
world lucifero suddenly the 30 minutes
are up and aston liebe are finally able
to enter double union mode again but
this time they enter unaltered devil
union form a samurai inspired form that
is specifically designed to accommodate
asta's fourth sword and yami's former
katana the demon slasher sword asta then
does some epic iaido moves as he
prepares to make the big cut and the
panels showcasing these moves mirrored
the panels we've seen from yami before
especially during the battle against
zagred once he's ready to go asta uses
an epic new spell demon slasher infinity
slash equinox and he uses this spell to
straight up cut the lucifero monster in
half vertically this spell is inspired
by yami's dark magic spell called dark
cloaked dimension slash equinox the very
spell that he had used to cut zagret in
half back in chapter 211. everyone is
shocked as the giant monster begins to
crumble into pieces and then we see that
both yami and william have been ejected
from the monster's insides and are safe
asta explains that the demon slasher has
the unique ability to choose exactly
what it cuts this is likely related to
the sharpness and accuracy of a katana
sword compared to other types of swords
and also it's magic so you know let's
roll with it essentially the demon
slasher can cut through that which asta
wants to destroy like lucifero's
monstrous incarnation but it will never
cut the things that asta wants to
protect like captain yami and i guess
william as both of asta's mentors yami
and knocked smile and scream out you
pulled it off asta this insane chapter
comes to an end and now we have really
entered the end game yami is now free
again and conscious so that means that
he is able to join the fight william
just kind of smashed into the remnants
of the black bull mecca and he seems
knocked out so yeah poor william doesn't
look like he'll be getting much more
relevant to the story anytime soon but
who knows maybe when juno shows up they
can have some sort of bro teamwork
moment maybe to all the william fans out
there please let me know how you feel
about william's role in the story and
what if anything do you think he is
going to contribute to this fight i look
forward to reading the comments from
both of you now we need to talk about
asta's new spell and new form and the
importance of demon slasher moving
forward but first let's just kind of
survey the situation on the battlefield
in order to get a sense of where things
will go from here now that asta was able
to slash through the lucifero monster
and rescue yami and william it might
seem like the battle is over right i
mean without yami and william the cliff
off can't stay open so presumably
lucifer will fail to manifest and
everything will go back to normal except
of course that is highly unlikely we are
clearly not at the end of this arc yet
we haven't even seen all the devils from
the second gate of the cliffhoth and
frankly there are still a ton of
unresolved plot points like the fourth
sogratis siblings to name just one big
one and don't even get me started on the
fact that we haven't seen even a
fraction of sekei's full power so it is
highly likely that even without yammy
and william lucifero will continue to
pose a threat i'm not sure how exactly
maybe his manifestation has crossed the
threshold from the underworld to this
world so it can't just be stopped
anymore or maybe he will find some other
way to keep the cliff off open but
either way it's almost certain that this
battle and this arc will not end here
yami's rescue means that he will now be
able to join the others in the fight and
with how strong he is and how strong
dark magic is against devils this is an
absolutely major development asta's new
form has been heavily inspired by yami
and yami's techniques so i think that
aston yami engaging in some epic
teamwork together is bound to happen and
i can't wait to see it it's safe to say
that the battle will continue after this
point and also and the black bulls are
going to need some major power ups in
order to defeat lucifero and potentially
the other highest ranked devils with
that in mind what power-ups do you guys
think we are about to see especially in
terms of yami and asta potentially
working together i recently made a whole
theory video on what asta's ultimate
power up and form will look like and i
argue that he will eventually unlock
black hole magic which is the ultimate
form of anti-magic black holes can alter
gravity space and time so it's the
ultimate weapon against the gravity
magic spatial magic and time magic
devils i will link that full video down
in the description if you want to check
it out but with yami's dark magic and
osta's anti-magic working together
against the devils i can definitely see
some black hole magic power up coming
soon and i am excited don't forget to
tell me where you guys think the story
is going from here is lucifero really
defeated and if not how is he going to
survive asta's attack and the rescue of
yami and william will the rules of the
cliff of change yet again is something
else going on behind the scenes let me
know down below if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more videos
like it in the future just leave a quick
like it only takes a second but it helps
with the youtube algorithm and if you're
new to anime uproar or maybe you watch
our videos but you just haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you really
have to go through the trouble of
subscribing hitting the bell and then
selecting that option that says all if
you don't do that you're still going to
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror i want to give a
quick thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible special thanks to
alpha sigma this man is an absolute mad
lad and a disciple of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including ingrada algital
pate heffa the red-haired fox hinokamine
water the toasted chi corey mcgowan the
spike lonely the car dylan isidor spidey
life tinel tungsten tarkis big buddhist
jeremy comments and che whitley finally
thank you also to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel cruz very gucci
alicia octor bonnie parks joanne garcia
fat boy games kaido might be a duck
jessica rabbit jeremy phillips alivania
and temple if you enjoy our videos and
you feel that they provide value to you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these legendary people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
foreign
[Music]